uh you did make a nice analogy here to
retail
with tiffany jcpenney and walmart yeah
so
i'm sure this made you a lot of friends
but you're basically saying tiger global
is the walmart of this
and that's i had to make it like a
backhanded compliment you know yeah
exactly
you've learned well uh um so and then
benchmark or sequoia being the tiffany
like
or founder's friend or founder's friend
yes i'm you said i'm an lp in both
founders fun and sequoia so i'm not in
benchmark happy lp yeah yeah how very
happy actually
i just got a i just got a couple of
shares in a company called uber because
it turns out
founders fund was in this other company
called postmates so it worked that's
okay
i was like oh or more uber shares coming
over okay okay
i could take some more of those sure i
know how those work
uh so tell me a little bit about this uh
analogy here i'm pulling the graphic up
for those of you watching on youtube or
the video version of the podcast
awesome yeah so so when i was thinking
about what was happening in venture
really what came to mind and this came
from kind of like my pe days thinking
about like non-tech businesses but over
the last two decades
you've seen something called the middle
squeeze um in kind of consumer retail
and it was driven by these really
low-cost really hyper-scale really
convenient
um new businesses that popped up or at
least scaled
to to kind of the scale that they're at
so costco amazon
walmart and what happened was you have
this bifurcation of consumer spending um
where you know people that want to spend
on luxury brands are going to spend on
luxury brands
because it's a flex because they get to
show off to their friends because it
makes them feel
warm and gooey inside like they're going
to buy the iphone they're going to buy
the
tiffany ring for their girlfriend
they're going to do those things and
then on the other side
you now have the walmart's amazon's
costcos of the world
which not only are of such scale that
they can pass on a ton of cost savings
to you
they're also just way more convenient
you know with amazon you're getting
the the shirt or the jeans or whatever
you want uh the toilet paper in one to
two days
and so what you saw in retail was there
was all of these
uh retailers jcpenney macy's all these
things that kind of just existed
mostly because amazon walmart et cetera
didn't exist
like you didn't really have another
place to go and get you know a cheap
sweater
that was still pretty high quality but
with the emergence of amazon and costco
in walmart there really ceased to exist
to be a reason
to go to a jcpenney it's like if you can
get just as high of a quality
of a shirt from amazon and they ship it
to you in one day why the hell are you
going to go to the mall
you know 30 minutes from your house and
go buy a jcpenney sweater and so which
by the way jcpenney
professor galloway's number one pick to
beat uber and airbnb
that literally that guy it's so dumb
you just go uh yeah whatever he's doing
you take the other side of the trade and
that might be like the best hedge fund
in the last 20 years
for sure i mean he thought jcpenney was
going to crush everybody it's like
literally the dead zone
the dead zone yeah it's literally the
dead zone